hello sal here from khan academy so when
you hear the word meditation for many of
y'all it might evoke some type of new
age thing that has nothing to do with
standardized tests and if you're about
to take a standardized test i'm sure
there's many thoughts about
am i prepared am i going to do well i
hope i don't bomb the exam
that stress and that anxiety is if
anything going to hurt your performance
on these things that you want to do well
and so meditation is a way to help still
that but it's really just for you to
observe your thoughts not get stressed
out about it if your thoughts start to
wander but then just bring them back and
try to not think or think about just
very positive thoughts and i think if
you do that you're going to find you're
going to be happier you're going to be
more positive all sorts of positive
energy is going to be attracted to you
and even though that's not the most
important thing in the world you'll do
just fine on these tests that right now
you might be worrying about
you